hello and welcome to this video playing
xiu xiu xiu xiu nua rope and sicilian
curly a night off that's what you get
most of the time I kind of remember as I
had this against him in earlier game
yeah I had this and I got into trouble
and these that's what I remember we had
this that was there was a queen trader
Quincy 75 I think that was this game
where he got the screen trade in all of
a sudden maybe I can prevent this now by
killing 2 f2 or something I don't know
if this is a good square but cannot be
terrible i think would be surprising
this will be completely bad how much
so we're treating this to prepare
probably prepare g5 and so on I wonder
if he if it goes deep okay d 5 x 85 at
this typical trick if he takes it Bishop
f4 wins the Queen's oh whoa talking
about typical tricks here's here's one
black that's nice let's need okay but
and I'm not obliged to take this right I
can go to g2 let's say what's happening
if I do that see meeting me or something
I don't think so now I am threatening to
take this right yep I was right about
that so I wonder if I should take it I
think this is not so bad just just take
the bloody thing and now get on with my
attack here let's let's do that the
night I look dangerous and now my king
seems fairly safe for the moment yeah of
course greed is good it's taking this
just being greedy yeah d forces on the
cards certainly
and to be ready to interpose them it
takes f words that then I'm calling the
cops the day I didn't do that okay night
h5 to f6 as an attacking idea i don't
know if it's dangerous to be honest i
can try though I mean let's just drive
it could be could be dangerous I mean
what if you can take everything here
okay so Knight f6 isn't that a bit
dangerous at least I can take the
exchange but this Duchess half of the
story I mean I will never should take
the exchange I can also play Queens you
for with the way the tempo
let's do this first and then next I can
also do you know we should be five I
cannot take one g7 but let's say it goes
Bishop d6 I might be able to take on g7
for Queen h5 that's definitely dangerous
I'd still have 9 f 6m so check so take
here d7 take the check you just threaten
three chicks at four
okay so what's the deal g6 Bishop here
all kinds of things could work okay just
try to open the position further and
when you have two minutes left it
doesn't do much sure that this actually
threatened something night xf6 could be
something I was trying to promote the
pawn anyway I mean this is also I mean
look at this position from blacks
perspective this is hell how to play
what about this that's skirts
let the thing I mean maybe it wasn't
defensible anyway but it's it's hell
this kind of position you have no king
position and maybe you had something to
defend this I kind of doubt it but okay
so what's going on here taking on g4 on
what's what's what's going on here I
take taking this is probably not working
you know okay let's just move the Queen
nothing fancy so take on T for 1d
threatening something i don't know let's
just do this and try to keep the
initiative not threatening all that much
in hmm it's cowardly as g8 covered quite
well so i didn't see this correctly but
the position still sucks I mean what
what exactly is playa
I don't see it can take him
no that doesn't work for black I didn't
play that well but I think it's enough
time morning
check oops check check black resigns
yeah why it's tough to evaluate those
positions I don't know at the beginning
I don't think this attack wasn't
particularly correct but yeah it turned
out turned out dangerous yeah if I've
that was tricky and counter tricky I
mean this is you need way of winning the
Queen but this is a funny move I have
seen this I've seen this motif but I
didn't think over there absolutely not
so my queen moved you went yep and I
think this shouldn't be all that bad i
think i've got a fairly safe King
position and have some and taking
chances the computer completely dislikes
my position this is probably more
objective than what i did but i really
wonder is it that bad I mean I feel like
my king is safe and I'm and I'm pushing
here maybe I'm not ever succeeding with
the attack that's possible so when an
engine wants to do this and thinks I'm
Bruce maybe i am now if he's the tech
arrives it arrives with a vengeance
probably him okay so I I didn't really
care about pawns him and just fired I
know this looks dangerous for me
dangerous to me like too dangerous what
he did five now I am so this is the game
night FC check if you can never take
next it's going to be made went here and
now look f1 yeah i'll check it that's
the bit to the bit to compute the rich
for my taste yeah efore
with the win for black that's the kind
of kind of thing that is difficult for a
human to do not so much for the engine I
mean it's not threatening my bishop but
maybe you should like playing Bishop b5
next completely cold blooded might
refute my free fruit my attack looks
like it I think the engine is probably
completely correct in this position
there's no slower check sometimes engine
does underestimate slower text but this
is very very directive even though I
doubt that this position is to be
evaluated slightly better for black it's
either I mean what-what exactly means
slightly bad it from plaque in this
position now it's so difficult to play
Queen c6 given by the computer okay well
this looks good for him right the bishop
comes here my night is in a tight spot
yeah that looks good instead he played
this move but this is like easy to
overlook here if it easy to overlook
this is check very unlucky spot for him
he now has to check it up shut up the
house and then we can were playing
playing older with the p's up okay hmm I
think I'm okay up to here but this is
actually the engine move that's funny
with age five yeah i mean it is probably
a total win i confirmed by the computer
of it check check check hmm yeah it's
tough for those positions are tough
it'sit's kind of fishy probably wants a
check but it's very very difficult to
play in an in a real game ok guys thanks
for watching